[Musique]
cette crise sanitaire arrive pendant une
crise un petit peu plus diffuse un petit
peu plus un petit peu plus au fond je
dirai qui et qui est la crise de de
mutation de l'industrie automobile on
voit bien qu'il ya une transition vers
l'électro mobilité d'une part et dans
vingt ans on a bien sûr la révolution
numérique et qui ce qui se dresse là
dessus les technologies numériques qui
vont être fortement le véhicule de
demain
on peut penser bien sûr aux véhicules
connectés vous 4g et 5g ou aux véhicules
autonomes
aujourd'hui vous avez des vous avez vous
a fait un petit peu de temps libre
et là c'est parce qu'il ya moins
d'activités mais pourquoi ne pas faire
un focus sur les appels à projets qui
sont qui sont aujourd'hui ouverts on
prévoir le développement de technologies
de demain
[Musique]
séduit la plusieurs domaines de
prédilection est plus un secteur mais le
premier comme vous le savez c'est
l'automobile on a été impacté par le
ralentissement des activités de no2 du
groupe clients français que sont psa et
renault
segula innove en permanence et j'allais
dire peut-être encore plus maintenant
en fait c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
un levier pour prendre des rester
compétitif quand le marché va repartir
[Musique]
que tu y allant d'une ovation sont des
sondés excellent moyen pour les grands
comptes
de source et d'acquérir rapidement des
compétences pour pouvoir sortir
rapidement des produits compétitifs
il était question voilà de laisser aux
participants jusqu'au 10 septembre pour
déposer leur dossier de candidature
puis les dossiers seront examinés du pop
art séculaire d'autre part pas mauvais
au moins seront examinées et les
finalistes seront invités à pitch est de
8 octobre en présentiel de tous les
experts de deux cellules en
[Musique]
il se trouve qu'au niveau du département
de recherche et innovation de ces
buts-là en travaille depuis longtemps
sur des innovations soit sur des
énergies des énergies propres soit sur
des projets de mobilité plus durable
on a lancé chez segula en fin d'année
dernière
un dispositif qui s'articule explora h x
p l'eau est rare qu'on présente comme un
hub de start up avec segula clint
challenge moveo on est vraiment à la
recherche de jeunes entreprises que nos
compétences pourrait leur permettre
d'accélérer et de gagner en performance
et peut-être en time to market aussi la
mobilité les transports l'énergie et aux
nouveaux matériaux ce sont les trois
grands domaines les champs d'exploration
de ceux de ce challenge